news daily from science mission fragile
x mental retardation protein fmr p and
it's autosomal paralog FX r2p
rna-binding proteins that have been
implicated in autism and are required
for neuronal maturation but the
mechanism is not known authors in cell
reports show that FX r2p binds and
stabilizes glue a1 mrna and enhance a
subsequent protein expression whereas f
MRP promotes blue a1 membrane delivery
thus both proteins play an important but
unique role with the same protein in
neuronal development next researchers
show that dietary glycemic index has a
significant impact on the autism
spectrum disorder phenotype by using an
inbred strain of minds that displays
behavioral traits that reflect
diagnostic symptoms of aht scientists
found that low glycemic that modulates
plasma metabolites neuroinflammation and
brain markers of neurogenesis in a
manner to reduce HD symptoms researchers
do not understand the mechanism but
speculate that good bacteria that digest
complex carbohydrates might play a role
for more news visitors at ww since
mission calm or science mission facebook
page thanks for what